[Music]
let them see your true qualities my poor
judgment your sense of humor
your majesty mr. Churchill I invite you
to take up the position of Prime
Minister she's an actor the collapse of
Western Europe in the next few days you
are solid victory you're suggesting
we're somehow winning we're not is it
true we're in full retreat all our
forces are known Dunkirk
where we cannot reach them they're
pushing us into the sea
there is the question of peace talks
between ourselves in Germany you're
rubbish still Europe is lost no choice
you have the full weight of the world on
your shoulders
how many men was fire going to the
people tell them the truth
these trousers to liberate resistance
the nothing battery on it in fighting to
the end now is the time to negotiate
when they learn you cannot reason with a
tiger when your hair use it is from a
month I take full responsibility really
really yes it is the reason I sit in
this chair
himself wash them
I survived all the visions we shall
fight on the landing grounds we shall
fight in the fields and in the streets
we shall fight in the Hills we shall
never forget
for Williams victory here can be no
sunlight
[Music]